hi guys welcome to the set of MasterChef
now first of all I big thank you for
subscribing to my new channel but more
importantly an even bigger thank you for
watching me a billion times that's right
we have gone through 1 billion of you I
can't believe you will see this mug a
billion times you guys crazy
now I've invited one of the hottest one
of the most sought-after actually
anywhere in the world to challenge me
this young lady is known as the Gordon
Ramsay of Riverdale
please welcome welcome Thank You
Madeline please come on down oh man
right first of all congratulations what
a huge success you have a reputation for
being firm assertive and somewhat feisty
which I love yes I do yes I get told
every day by my daughters but you know I
go back a long way
I actually was a production assistant on
MasterChef junior your team of told me
you're a serious foodie stop it
joking come on stop the jokes with you
jokes later now you love a challenge
under those boxes I've been told of some
incredible ingredients and we'll go
ahead to have and have an amazing cook
off we go let's go let's go please it's
your box there now in the apron you'll
see a little surprise for me in here yes
look at that
[Music]
there you go come on now I feel so
officially ready
I'm almost ready I've got no idea what
some of these boxes I'm hoping you've
given me something a low stake yeah
now I feel at home on the count of three
we'll lift our boxes okay ready one two
three lift
[Laughter]
your dreambox my what my dream box yes
dates mushrooms cauliflower that looks
like my granddad's armpit kelp noodles
cauliflower peas chickpeas finally
cashew nuts oh no no my grandma's loofah
who put the squeaky tofu so let's get
this right this is a vegan challenge
vegan challenge you just turned master
chef into a master vegan are you ready
yes oh yeah mark get set let's go what
don't even chopping I got in here there
they are
nice amazing now when was last time you
cook this dish that's a steak a steak of
cauliflower a beautiful steak I can't
believe I'm saying that cauliflower
steak she'll be a ribeye steak not
cauliflower steak
you're actually doing their breakdown
with the staff and I'm sad that I'm
loving here yes it's my first time ever
zesting a lemon skull boot and you can't
read your recipe anymore oh my god we
didn't know if you're gonna cook with me
always cook your mind to go I need three
other industry yes I need you I need you
to focus in go grandma's hair go into
the see the equipment room there's a
blast chiller in there I've got a little
present in there for you
I just put my cabbage yeah I'll look
after kelp noodles trust me back fridge
no that's it through there right the
very back the blast chillers the top
shelf
[Music]
top shelf you got it
oh sorry it's here the station I left
few bottle of water I'm sorry no no I
need to go into the school back in one
minute please
you okay you sure yep coming now alright
are you really that confident that
you're gonna win that you're gonna go
back there and just hang out that's
better sorry just setting something in
the fridge oh man sorry your dad sure
that you're gonna win that you're just I
just I need to go into that fridge just
for two minutes right cauliflower
roasted chickpeas do beautifully never
are you okay is this a joke did you say
you needed egg yolk what was that with
this challenge are you talking to
yourself yeah I have a YouTube channel
so I'm kind of like what I do what are
you doing I think I took a break we're
down to three minutes to go no the
battery's wrong we haven't changed it
what we've done I'm gonna start plating
literally time flies in the kitchen
[Music]
we are literally nine seconds away we're
having a master vegan off Gordon you
gotta go buddy yes yes yes recitations
on the line get that boot on Playgirl is
it late
thirty Seconds to go it's time to get
that plate yes freshness mama maybe some
lemon zest just taste a taste I'm not
gonna taste it I'm the first ever
MasterChef vegan cook-off we know it's
all in the taste all right let's do this
Gordon you're up first present your dish
please
here I have a delicious marinated steak
of cauliflower dusted in blood of on
spiced finished with the most amazing
garlic onion chickpea with a beautiful
fine tomato puree pour together finish
with a noble vinaigrette and zest it
with fresh lemons the flavors okay it's
a little bulky it's a little hefty you
know it's interesting the reason I
actually came out I was sitting just
doing a little bit of work and I saw two
cast-iron pans passed by my dress
with what looked remarkably like these
cauliflower steak and chickpea what is
that that's we both start ganging up on
me
you know have you broken all of the
rules of the MasterChef kitchen and this
need you can cook off you know what it
was he was too scared of all of this
let's see how your competitor did let's
dive into Madeleine cold noodles what's
the dish kelp noodles with some kale
pesto and there's pine nuts and such
beautiful yeast olive oil garlic tell
moodle's that pesto just needs more
seasoning
the pesto itself is right it's fresh the
basil pine nuts are really nice go eat
this for lunch
Gordon Madeleine please come around to
the front I've already accepted defeat
is the king of me against ice-cream the
winner of the first ever MasterChef
vegan cook-off is